my belief is that we need to
collectively as 8 billion people create
a better conversation around grieving
the answer to the question is give
yourself time to grieve it's just okay I
feel no pressure on getting back to work
I really don't I will grieve because I
haven't been through it it might take me
an hour because I could see that knowing
my chemicals and it could take me four
months and by the way there's two
profound moments in life the moment
someone is born and the moment that
someone dies and I think that they
should be understood and we should go
deeper into them and I think we have to
be more supportive of grieving and
letting people go through it I think
that people judge themselves too much my
sister's back to work and doing great
why am I sitting in this dark room sad
about my dad because that's how you feel
that's okay and I think we need to have
that combo